ya hemos visto que los valores
permitidos para el número cuántico de
espn son un medio positivo o un medio
negativo verdad así que un electrón
puede tener una espina hacia arriba o un
spin hacia abajo y recordemos que el
espín lo obtenemos justamente entre
comillas lo tenemos entre comillas
porque no podemos visualizar realmente
si el electrón está realmente girando
sobre su eje verdad realmente no es lo
que está haciendo así que simplemente le
llamamos el número cuántico de espn así
que digamos que tenemos dos electrones
verdad cada uno digamos que tiene un
spin hacia arriba que digamos y si nos
ponemos a pensar bien un electrón es una
carga que se está moviendo verdad y una
carga que se está moviendo produce
campos magnéticos verdad así que en
realidad un electrón simplemente es un
pequeño imán verdad y cuando tenemos 222
electrones con el espín con digamos con
un spin paralelo entonces los campos más
de esos electrones se añade en verdad se
juntan así que llamamos a esta situación
para magnética bien a esta situación
justamente le llamamos para magnética
los campos magnéticos de los electrones
se suman o se añaden ahora si tenemos
una situación en donde tenemos un
electrón cuyo spin digamos apunta hacia
arriba y el spin del otro electrón
apunta hacia abajo entonces los campos
magnéticos de dichos electrones se
cancelan mutuamente verdad y es a esta
situación justamente a la que llamamos
vía magnética así que vamos a movernos
hacia abajo para ver la definición de
para magnético muy bien
así que según esta definición algo que
es para magnético digamos un material
para mí para magnético es algo que tiene
uno o más electrones alineados y de
hecho vimos un ejemplo en donde teníamos
dos electrones verdad dos electrones que
tenían sus spin es alineados pero por
supuesto también podríamos haber tenido
sólo un electrón verdad solo un electrón
sin otro que lo acompañe ok entonces
este pequeño electrón sería justamente
como un imán muy pequeño verdad con su
propio campo magnético y algo que es
para magnético justamente es atraído
hacia un campo magnético externo verdad
es atraído por un campo magnético
externo y podríamos ver si un una
muestra de un materiales para magnético
no utilizando una balanza especial que
por ejemplo aquí tengo dibujada verdad
tengo esta imagen de esta balanza
y digamos que nuestra digamos nuestra
muestra para magnéticas se encuentra
justamente aquí muy bien que estoy
pintando digamos en magenta y por
supuesto todavía no lo hemos encendido
verdad así que aquí tenemos por ejemplo
un imán verdad aquí tenemos el polo
norte el polo sur y antes de encender
nuestro imán digamos aquí colocamos
nuestra muestra para para para magnética
ok y digamos además que está balanceada
digamos con esta justamente con esta
balanza está balanceada perfectamente y
está balanceada con respecto a este peso
que tenemos del lado derecho
pongamos por ejemplo también un pivote
aquí y vamos a suponer que todo está
completamente bien balanceado muy bien
ahora si encendemos nuestro imán si
encendemos el imán las líneas magnéticas
se dirigen de norte a sur entonces cómo
tenemos electrones que están digamos de
sap área 2 es decir tienen digamos el
espín los uses pines son paralelos
verdad nuestro nuestra muestra para
magnética va a ser atraída hacia este
campo magnético externo queremos
justamente encendido verdad va a ser
atraído hacia esta dirección es decir
hacia abajo
y por supuesto todo esto va a ser
atraído en esta dirección es más voy a
voy a dibujarlo un poquito mejor lo
vamos a dibujar encima do aquí
tendríamos nuestra muestra nueva verdad
y qué es lo que le ocurre a nuestra
balanza bueno justamente tendremos este
mismo digamos podríamos pensar que es un
cable y como ha bajado nuestra muestra
entonces esta balanza esta balanza se
inclinara en esta dirección verdad esta
es física simple es física simple y
justamente al haber girado nuestra
balanza muy bien quizás debería mejorar
la imagen de la barra entonces al haber
girado nuestra barra tendríamos que el
peso del lado derecho se habrá levantado
cierto ahí tenemos la nueva posición del
peso que teníamos del lado derecho
en resumen pareciera como si nuestra
muestra paramagnética hubiera ganado
peso y por supuesto no es que haya
ganado peso verdad simplemente está
experimentando una fuerza así que hay
una fuerza magnética debido a que es una
sustancia para magnética y ya es y esta
balanza nos permite descubrir si algo es
para magnético o no así que ahora
vámonos a la definición de día magnético
que cuando algo es día magnético así que
para un un material día magnético
tendremos que todos sus electrones están
apareados verdad es decir que si tengo
un electrón cuyo spin apunta hacia
arriba entonces necesariamente debe
haber otro electrón cuyo spin apunte
hacia abajo así que los campos
magnéticos se cancelan verdad y por lo
tanto una muestra díaz magnética no
sería atraída por ningún campo magnético
externo de hecho produce su propio campo
magnético en la dirección opuesta verdad
y por lo tanto
es débilmente repelido por cualquier
campo magnético externo así que tenemos
estas dos definiciones para un material
para magnético y un material día
magnético y podemos descubrir si los
átomos o los iones son para magnéticos o
díaz magnéticos al escribir sus
configuraciones electrónicas así que
vamos a fijarnos en una versión
recortada digamos de nuestra tabla
periódica y fijémonos en algunos
elementos así que vamos a considerar
algunos elementos para determinar si son
para magnéticos o díaz magnéticos así
que vamos a empezar con el helio muy
bien que se encuentra justamente aquí y
tenemos que escribir la configuración
electrónica para el helio verdad así que
esto sería 1s 1
s 2 muy bien así que por supuesto estoy
suponiendo que ya sabes cómo escribir
configuraciones electrónicas como lo
hemos visto en vídeos anteriores así que
tenemos que el helio tiene una
configuración electrónica 1 s 2 lo cual
significa que los dos electrones se
encuentran en un orbital 1s verdad así
que los dos
digamos que aquí está el orbital 1s
entonces ambos se encuentran en este
orbital de esta forma así que sus
spinners están apareados verdad
justamente los electrones están
completamente apareados y eso significa
que el helio es día magnético el el ibex
magnético y deberíamos decir no el helio
sino los átomos de helio son los que son
ya magnéticos vamos a hacer otro vamos a
hacer digamos ahora el átomo de carbono
muy bien aquí tenemos el carbono en la
tabla periódica y si quisiera escribir
la configuración electrónica para el
carbono
entonces sería 1 s 2 verdad 2 s 1 2 s 2
y luego tendríamos 2 p 1 y 2 p 2 así que
para el carbono la configuración
electrónica sería 1 s 2 2 s 2 y 2 p 2
ahora si escribimos la anotación orbital
tendríamos que poner aquí el orbital 1 s
el orbital 2s y finalmente los orbitales
2 p verdad entonces primero tendríamos
estos dos electrones que se encuentran
en el orbital 1 s 2 electrones que se
encuentran en el orbital 2s y tenemos
que seguir la regla de hong verdad
tenemos que colocar los dos electrones
que faltan en los orbitales p pero no
queremos aparear los verdad no queremos
que se encuentran en el mismo orbital y
por lo tanto lo colocamos en dos
orbitales distintos con el espín
paralelo muy bien
así que si nos fijamos en el resultado
final tenemos 2 electrones que no estan
apareados verdad si tenemos 2 electrones
que no están atareados eso quiere decir
que el átomo de carbono es para
magnético el átomo de carbono es para
magnético
muy bien ahí lo tenemos ahora vamos con
otro ejemplo vamos a considerar ahora el
sodio muy bien vamos a considerar el
átomo de sodio tenemos que escribir su
configuración electrónica así que
tendría que ser 1s 22 s 22 p 6 verdad
aquí tenemos 21 22 23 24 25 y 26 y
finalmente tendríamos que aquí sería al
estaríamos en el orbital 3s y esto sería
3s 1 entonces para el sodio para el
sodio tendríamos 1s 212 2 2p 6 y 3 s 1
muy bien así que si nos fijamos ahora en
nuestra anotación orbital tendríamos
aquí el orbital 1 s el orbital 2 s
tendríamos los tres orbitales 2
y más arriba tendríamos el orbital 3s
muy bien así que tendríamos lleno el
primero orbital 1s lleno el orbital 2s
tendríamos primero tres electrones en
los tres orbitales 2p y luego
completamos los tres orbitales 2 p hasta
este momento llevamos 2 468 10
electrones y en realidad tenemos 11 lo
cual quiere decir que tenemos un
electrón en el orbital 3s y si tenemos
un electrón que no tiene que no está
aparejado eso significa que el átomo es
para magnético nuevamente tenemos un
ejemplo en donde es para magnético
para magnético así que el átomo de sodio
es para magnético ahora vamos a hacer un
caso un poco distinto vamos a considerar
unión de sodio muy bien vamos a
considerar el lyon de sodio así que el
átomo de sodio tiene el mismo número de
protones que de electrones pero el lyon
de sodio significa que hemos perdido uno
de esos electrones verdad así que hemos
perdido este electrón que se encuentra
en la última capa muy bien así que el
lyon de sodio tiene esta configuración
electrónica 1 s 2 12 s 22 p 6 hemos
perdido un electrón y que se encuentra
justamente en la última capa verdad y lo
que hay que notar para este guión es que
ahora tenemos todos los electrones
apareados verdad así que todo aquí se
encuentra apareado y tenemos todos los
electrones apareados y por lo tanto
estamos hablando de una sustancia díaz
magnética
el lyon de sodio es ya magnético verdad
y esto en realidad todo esto se trata de
escribir las configuraciones
electrónicas y recordar cuáles son las
definiciones para algo que es día
magnético y algo que es para magnético